à notre dossier du jour dans ce dossier
on va parler de l'éducation nationale
dimanche soir M6 a publié un numéro
exclusif de zone interdite sur les
failles de l'éducation nationale vous
allez voir les extraits sont
complètement fous on va en parler ce
soir avec Nicolas gllier professeur et
porte-parole du mouvement des stylos
rouges que vous connaissez qui vient
souvent nous voir avant tout regardz ces
images de violence dans les
établissements scolaires des images qui
sont malheureusement de plus en plus
nombreuses on en avit parlé déjà
vendredi regardez lors de l'infiltration
de Paul un matin son lycée est encerclé
par la police un élève s'est fait lycher
la veille devant la grille élè on filmé
la scène d'une extrême
brutalité en 2018 cet élève menace sa
prof avec une arme
factice dans ce collège cet ado s'en
prend violemment à sa prof qui tentait
de l'empêcher de quitter son
cours
Wes par terre
Wes Nicolas merci d'être avec nous
professeur et porte-parole du mouvement
des des stylos rouges vous avez ces
images c'est c'est courant ça alors dans
mon établissement pas du tout en
revanche oui il y a de nombreux
témoignages d'enseignants qui subissent
des violences d'ailleurs les styl rougge
sont nés suite à pas de vague le hashtag
pas de vague c'était en novembre 2018
c'était c'était ça cétait exactement
ceci ouis c'est ça euh ça fait des
années qu'on dénonce la violence dans
les écoles rien n'est fait on ne punit
pas les auteurs le documentaire de d'M6
de zone Inter le montrait extrêmement
bien on ne fait rien il y a une espèce
de mièvre bienveillance une niaiserie
constante on va va pas punir ceux qui
perturbent les cours on va pas punir
ceux qui sont violents on va laisser
faire parce que ça serait être méchant
concrètement c'est le message que le
ministère nous donne c'est le message
que la société nous a donné pendant des
décennies et ça donne un résultat
catastrophique pour le vivre ensemble
alors il y avait un exemple avec cet
élève qui apporte un faux pistolet en
classe dans le but d'harceler un
camarade handicapé qui pourtant reste en
cours regardez un élève a fait entrer ce
pistolet à bille dans le lycée parfaite
réplique d'une arme à feu elle était
destiné à impressionner un lycéen
handicapé harcelé depuis des semaines
l'adolescent av ça est maintenant
tranquillement tranquille il reste en
cours le temps qu' la sanction soit posé
en dans la salle des profs personne
n'est surpris par le manque de réaction
du lycée et aussi cette professeur qui a
été aspergé de gaz lacrymogène alors
qu'elle avait pourtant interpellé
plusieurs fois sa hiérarchie avant
regardez mon ordinateur et cagoul est
entré il m'a aspergé boutortant de gaz
lacrémogène j'ai eu peur d'être défiguré
j'ai eu peur d'être aveugle avant cette
agression Catherine veille avait déjà
essuyé des insultes et des menaces de la
part de plusieurs élèves j'étais agressé
verbalement sale [__] est-ce que vous
êtes juive madame vous voulez qu'on
chuchote en TP comme Anne FR et tout
j'ai fait des tas de rapport et pas que
moi pour seul réponse le rectorat avait
proposé à l'enseignante de la muter dans
un autre établissement
ou il y a un sondage fait en 2021 auprès
d'une mutuelle 30 % des des professeurs
ont été victimes de violence et deux
professeurs sur TR ont été témoins de
violence directement ça veut dire que
c'est un fléo incroyable dans
l'éducation nationale je sais pas si
Jacques a des infos
là-dessus tu as vu le
doc tu as vu le doc maître de
Saint-Germain tu as V le doc bien sûr
non mais c'est c'est il a du mal non
c'est surtout un doc qui montre très
bien le l'impossibilité pour le
l'appareil de de de remplacer les les
profs notamment avec un logiciel qui est
vieux comme le monde qui fait que
eux-mêmes au sein de l'Éducation
nationales sont incapables de savoir qui
est dispible làdus disponible non mais
il a plus tris fois on est tellement mal
pay est payé depuis 3
Mo moi je trouve que pour une fois mais
vraiment pour une fois les réseaux
sociaux ont du bon dans le sens où
maintenant c'est dénoncé et on en parle
beaucoup plus parce que pardonnez-moi
mais ça existe depuis mais des années
alors moi c'est plus caché au moins
c'est l'avantageis tout à d'ord le
collège cétait il y a pas si longtemps C
il y a je sais pas 15 20 ans et et il y
avait déjà toutes ces choseslà que nous
on garde en mémoire mais que maintenant
on peut enfin dénoncer c'est ça alors il
y a un manque de professeurs aussi
l'éducation fait face à un manque cruel
de professeurs euh regardez le
professeur le problème c'est que ces
professeurs contractuels sont recrutés
sans véritable vérification une
journaliste de Zone Interdite a été
recruté seulement 15 minutes d'entretien
pour enseigner
l'espagnol donc regardez avec 3 années
d'études supérieur et aucune expérience
dans l'enseignement notre journaliste
n'a mis que 2 jours pour décrocher un
entretien téléphonique avec un rectorat
notre journaliste parle un peu
l'espagnol mais à dire vrai c'est plutôt
elle qui aurait besoin de cours bah
écoutez moi je pense donner un avis
favorable pour vous pour le collège ok
très bien c'est à peine Croy
elle est embauchée en 15 minutes chrono
par téléphone nous ne donnerons pas
suite ces collégiens méritent une vraie
professeur
d'espagnol ou et une fois recruté au
sein des établissements les journalistes
on pu se rendre compte de l'ampleur des
dégâts avec par exemple dans ce lycée 11
professeurs absents la même journée
regardez dès son arrivée sur ce tableau
notre journaliste découvre cette liste
impressionnante de 11 profs absents rien
que pour aujourd'hui la conséquence nous
allons le découvrir c'est une immense
pagaille vous faites quoi là il y a des
élèves partout errants dans les couloirs
qu'est-ce que tu fais dans les couloirs
toi dépêche-toi tous sont venus pour les
cours de 8h aucun d'entre eux n'a été
prévenu le grand jeu c'est de jouer à
cache-cache avec les surveillants pour
éviter la salle de permanence on les
comprend d 8h du matin elle est déjà
pleine à craquer
ouais c'est c'est courant ça ça arrive
en fait ça a été très bien montré dans
le documentaire en fait il monttrre
d'abord un absentéisme qui existe et
ensuite ils essaient de l'expliquer et
en gros qu'est-ce qu'on a on a des
établissementsù on peut plus faire cours
on a des établissements où il y a de la
violence des insultes où il y a pas de
niveau où les parents défendent leur
gamin coûte que coûte quoi qu'il fasse
même quand il plante quelqu'un forcément
on n pas envie d'aller travailler je ne
dis pas que c'est bien je dis juste que
c'est un constat c'est un état l'école
est dans un tel état notamment l'école
publique parce que on a laissé couler le
métier parce qu'on pa mal les gens parce
on ne recrute plus de gens compétents et
donc on se retrouve avec une école comme
ça avec des profs qui sont pas là des
postes non pourvus parce que plus
personne ne veut être prof j'insiste
vraiment là-dessus et des gens recrutés
qui n'ont pas le niveau en collège
compris on voit le mépris de
l'administration dans ce documentaire
ouais c'est bon tu parles pas espagnol
bah va enseigner en collège mais
attendez pour enseigner en collège il
faut avoir du niveau il faut avoir ce
bac plus 4 ou 5 peu importe ce qui sera
décidé par Monsieur Atal il faut avoir
les connaissances pour pouvoir tenir une
classe il faut tenir une classe avec de
la discipline de l'autorité mais aussi
avec les connaissances qui la
permettent par du niveau des certains
enseignants il y a Clara qui a eu 9
enseignants 4 mois et le niveau de
certains enseignant inquiète sa maman
regardeza a toujours eu un remplaçant
pour assurer les cours mais d'après sa
mère c'est un défilé de profs
incompétent et il y a aussi toutes les
fautes des élèves que ces profs n'ont
pas pris la peine de corriger voilà
l'animatrice voyez animatrice i
de et oui elle allait au fond de la
classe et elle mettait ses écouteurs
comme ça elle faisait ça après elle
écoutait vous vous faisiez quoi pendant
ce temp là
euh bah on lisait on faisait des dessins
mais je crois pas qu'elle écoutit de la
musique je crois plutôt qu'elle écouter
des trucs pour mieux apprendre le
français trop mignonne ouis mais moi je
enfin moi j'ai été tellement choquée en
fait pour moi tout commence là et tout
ce qu'on commmente nous tous les soirs
l' se la sociéé en fait on la VO là dans
lesèges dans les lycé en fait il y a
rien qui va aujourd'hui dans l'éducation
nationale mais rien qui va le laxisme
autorité on a été gangrainé par
l'idéologie post 68 il est interdit
d'interdire on peut pas punir les élèves
les parents qui se permettent de donner
des leçons au professeurs les
professeurs qui gagnent pas assez
d'argent qui sont méprisés par les
élèves en fait mais c'est cataclysmique
et moi quand je vois ça je me dis qu'en
fait mais on voit tout ce qui se passe
dans la société en fait c'est à cause de
ça et les rectorat c'est l'opacité
totale al là il y a les scènes sur
alors je vous le dis c'est rectorat
crétaille qu'on voit dans le
documentaire nous on le dénonce depuis
genre 10 ans c'est n'importe quoi ce
rectorat il est mal géré les gens sont
pas payés à temp c'est n dans le
reportage un professeur témoigneavoir
été payé pendant 3 mois sans avoir donné
de cours
regarde ce jeune prof de français n'a
reçu aucune affectation et n'a donné
aucun cours pendant 3 mois l'année
dernière payé à ne rien faire par
l'Éducation nationale jeis du sport je
fais des gâteaux je très tarte fine au
PUM si vous voulez et je touche un
salaire à la fin du mois avec vos impôts
cordialement
c'est horrible he c'est c'est c'est
dégueulasse comme système on est
d'accord de toute manière on peut on
peut pas peut pas y faire grand-chose on
a pas le droit d'en parler on a le droit
de rien dire donc on se contente
d'attendre et on se dit peut-être que
demain j'aurai une classe c'est fou ça
et dans certaines classes il y a même
pas de prof il y a l'exemple incroyable
de ce logiciel qui donne des cours
d'Allemands non mais sérieux et les
gamins passent une heure en fait avec
des problèmes technique donc et
plusieurs classes devant une VI Mar il y
a quatre classes qui sont branchées et
je te parle pas pas grave ah moi je te
parle ben ouais mais moi je te parle pas
je parle à Cyr maître vénéré de de
Saint-Germain au la voilà c'est pas mal
le logiciel il est branché sur quatre
classes et dans les quatre classes aucun
gamin ne peut suivre réellement le cours
puisque il y a des problèmes techniques
dans toutes les classes et et celui qui
a inventé le logiciel est devenu
directeur de cabinet de papend de
papay en félicitation alors que c'était
un aurage total et je suis pas sûr que
le niveau va c'est Sliman on vait au
début documentaire qui sert à Ren alors
oui oui et je suis pas sûr que le niveau
des profes va tellement s'améliorer
parce que je avant pour j'en étais resté
à l'époque c'était une sorte de vocation
des le prof et là je suis tombé sur la
radio sur les chansons sur une pub du
gouvernement qui disait un dialogue à la
machine à café entre deux deux salariés
tu t'emmerdes pas trop dans le boulot ah
si je me fais chier mais pourquoi tu
fais pas prof ouis ils ont B en ce
moment comme quoi genre B vas-y ouvre la
porte et T va quoi c'est incroyable
c'est mal raconté mais c'était
intéressant non mais c'est vra tu as dit
quoi d'intéressant depuis le début de
l'émission non mais fa comme ça c'est
bien ce que tu
dis vous le savez l'école fait face à
une forte augmentation du nombre de
signalement d'atteinte à la laïcité en
milieu scolaire Gabriel Atal a décidé
d'intertir labaya à la rentrée il semble
que ces règles soient difficiles à faire
respectter au sein des établissements
scolaires regardez on se décoifffe s'il
vous plaît mademoiselle à l'intérieur
d'établissement il vous plaî
mademoiselle mais elle fait mine de ne
rien entendre et un autre élève fait
barrage cont
[Musique]
pasintéeurétaissement vous connaissz la
RZ alors pouro
faire de cette réuniones questions vont
irriter
laction seul mot d'ordre pas de vague
franchement si c'est juste ça je propose
tolérant vraiment j'enien
oui le problème c'est que les conseils
ministériels c'est parfait mais c'est
inapplicable on l'avait dit ici
c'estàdire que c'est mais c'est pas
possible de suivre n'est-ce pas Jacques
contrairement à ce que tu peux dire
maître vénéré l'éducation nationale a
fait une erreur stratégique c'est qu'ils
ont pas donné d'autorisation de tournage
à M6 et résultat quand tu n'as pas
d'autorisation de tournage tu vas en
caméra caché
RAF tant mieux tant mieux mais tant
mieux pour eux non mais j'en profite
pour le dire parce que systématiquement
la communication croit que c'est en
cachant les choses que les journalistes
ne vont pas savoir mais c'est exactement
s produit et tant mieux pour la
démocratie parce que comme ça on sait ce
qui mie ou toi c'est bien tu fais des
bonnes
interventions en France il y a de plus
en plus d'établissements scolaires
délabrés regardez l'état de de certains
établissements
regardez fuite d'eau et insalubrité dans
ce collège délabement général en
tomouill en banlieu parisienne une
simple averse a transformé ce lycée en
club
aquatique en France 6 établissements sur
10 aur besoin d'urgence d'une rénovation
complète à Toulouse à Marseille ici à
Saint téléphon et en général il y a la
copine qui passe en dessous de la porte
pour mettre le flash comme ça mais c'est
vraiment pas agréable
quoi oui il y a des établissements il y
a pas de savon aussi régulièrement pas
de papier toilette sympa en fait on est
content de payer les impôts mais quand
on voit ça on dit qu'ils sont mal
utilisés quand mêmeroyable l'excuse d'
rectorat c'est dire c'est ce qui a dit
dans documentaire c'est de dire mais
attendez on a tellement de délabré que
ça a pas été fait depuis tellement
longtemps que il faut bien commencer on
peut pas tout faire en même temps ils
sont bien gentils mais ce sont des vrais
gens qui sont dedans ce sont des vrais
salariés qui bossent dedans des vrais
élèves qui sont dedans ce sont des vrais
gens et donc ils subissent des des des
conditions de travail détériorées
terribles il y a des dangers pour la
santé et rien ne se passe rien avance
tout est bloqué par une administration
procédurière lente qui se moque des des
des des comment on appelle ça des des
recours qu' fait des demandes qu'on fait
rien ne se passe derrière
rien ça oui vas-y non je voulais savoir
à qui la faute à qui la faute tout ça
parce que moi l'école l'école que j'ai
connu il y a pas eu ça donc à qui la
faute pourquoi les établissements ta
gueule toi c'est
il rien un laissé faire généralisé un
abandon généralisé à la question là
parce que tu veux que Monsieur réponde à
ta question ça y est lui toi tu te
prends pour le
maîre ça y est là tu commences à
distribuer la parole parce qu'il va
prendre ta quoi le le maître vénéré de
SaintGermain VO mer Saint-Germain en
lait il a raison c'est vrai tu te cends
pour qui là alors tu veux poser la
question distrib qui la faute à qui va
revenir la faute de tout ce qui se passe
actuellement ah mais à tout mais
vraiment je le dis sans euh sans
problème à toute la société à moi à vous
à tout le monde à chaque citoyen on a
tous oublié l'importance de l'école à
l'idéologie quiil y a eu je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous je me fais je
vais me faire défoncer par la moitié sty
rouge mais je suis d'accord avec vous il
a il y a une idéologie po 68 ARD pédago
et tout ce qu'on veut qui a démoli
l'école gentiment c'estàd qu'ils sont
partis du principe qu'ils allaient tout
améliorer en étant gentil en étant
bienveillant non il y a un moment il
faut poser un cadre il faut mettre des
limites il faut de la culture sans
culture la société par envr c'est ce qui
passe on voit tout à fait et donc il y a
un besoin de ça il faut revenir à
quelque chose comme ça je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec vous làdessus
voilà une autre question
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Pierre non c'était pas c'était pas
s rig une bonne question je suis désolé
à qui la faute c'est logitime qui la
faute oui bah oui bah oui c'est court
mais c'est sympa ça ça pose bien le
problème il y a eu un problème aussi au
niveau de de
quoi une baisse de niveau de ah oui oui
mais ça ou baisse de niveau ou c'est qu
il y a une baisse de niveau général ah
oui bah oui oh oui alors là on a déjà
des chiffres qui sont sortis les élèves
lisent moins bien qu'avant ils compte
moins bien qu'avant dans toutes les
études internationales on s'effondre
pareil on met plus les moyens dans
l'école et et puis dans les programmes
on met plus de moyens on n'est pas
ambitieux à qui la faute à qui la
[Rires]
faute a qui la faute au gouvernements
libéraux successifs qui sont succédés
avec les mêmes lignes idéologiques les
mêmes lignes idéologiques à l'école vous
avez la gauche la droite même programme
même constart même chose dans l'école
cétait pas une vraie question pas dicté
pas de machin et ben moi j réponds j'en
profite pour répondre justement dictci
la dicté c'est de la torture
merci un bonheur bravo Nicolas bravo
excellent